يوما بعد يوم تاخذ الحرب في اوكرانيا منحا
تصعيديا سواء بالمعارك او حتى السلاح
المستخدم والاهم الخسائر البشريه تصريحات
لافته لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم اعترفت
فيها بمقتل ثمانيه وسبعون جنديا بهجوم
اوكرانيه على معسكر تجنيد مؤقت في منطقه
مكيفك بدونيسكا شرقا اوكرانيا وذكرت
الوزاره ان الهجوم الاوكراني تم تنفيذه
بصواريخ هاي مارس شديده الانفجار وان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت اثنين منها ما
يقلقوا الروس ليس ما يجري داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وان كانت حصيله اليوم ثقيله
على موسكو لكن الخطر الاكبر لروسيا هو
اقتراب المعارك من اراضيها بحسب ما نقل
مراسل العربيه في موسكو لنا اليوم
تقتربوا الحرب الاوكرانيه من الاراضي
الروسيه اذا بشكل تدريجي نتحدث هنا عن حرب
المسيرات تحديدا الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الطويله ومفتوحه جغرافيا تمتد
على طول
2063 كم من المناطق الروسيه القريبه
للحدود الاوكرانيه اقليم بريانكا الذي
اعلن حاكمه اليوم ان مسيره اوكرانيه
استهدفت منشاه للطاقه دون وقوع اصابات
واضاف ان المسيره تنفذته هجوما على منطقه
كليموفيسكي دون وقوع اصابات الا ان مرافق
الطاقه تضررت ما ادى الى انقطاع الكهرباء
عن المنطقه
[موسيقى]
هذا في بريانكا لكن هناك مناطق اخرى
مدينه فارونيج
على المدينه التي تبعد عن الحدود 300 كيلو
متر طائره مسيره اعلنت موسكو اسقاطها من
قبل الدفاعات الجويه قبل وصولها الى
المدينه بينما افادت صفحات غير رسميه بان
الطائره سقطت وكان بالامكان سماعه ذوي
الانفجار مقاطع اخرى ايضا قريبه جدا من
الحدود الاوكرانيه اذا هذه مقاطعه قريبه
جدا من الحدود وهي بالجروب تعرضت مرارا
لهجوم بمسيرات اوكرانيه ضربت احداها مولد
الكهرباء ما ادى الى انقطاع الخدمه عن
اجزاء من المدينه الرئيس الروسيه
في الحادي والثلاثين من ديسمبر عندما كان
في مدينه روستوس الحدوديه او عزل الحكومه
بالتطوير الانظمه الجويه للمسيرات وقال ان
الهدفه هو تنفيذ سياسه الدوله هذا المجال
اضافه الى حل المشكلات المتعلقه بتطوير
وانتاجه واعتمادي وتشغيل الانظمه الجويه
غير الماهوله محددا الخامس عشر من فبراير
موعدا اقصى للتنفيذ
[موسيقى]